hi guys I'm Jamie Lee with the Peet home
celebrities are always asked the same
thing you know it's always like who are
you wearing you know I want to ask like
the tough questions what's it like to
have your face well I can't see it
unless I said a mirror um I would do
that like a lot if I were you
what's your biggest insecurity I feel
like it might be a very short list your
boobs look nice today it was really good
what is your favorite snack sorry I'm
just looking your eyes they are really
cool color oh thanks
how old are you love it so into it not
really what's your biggest insecurity my
biggest insecurity my penis size in the
winter in the winter shrinkage what
about you um my penis size in the summer
yeah swells up I don't want everyone to
know that I have a dick yes exactly
Colonna TV Israel has a long pop off ah
Thank You MTV Israel otherwise we would
not have gotten an interview with David
Hasselhoff how's your baby um little
peanut right now number two I usually
drink before these things and come here
yeah yeah alright squirt it out and then
go back to drinking okay bye you were
nominated for Best Kiss do you feel like
kind of awkward like every time anyone
talks to you tonight they're just gonna
be like staring at your mouth like I'm
doing right now no are you hungry right
now
no really I'm so hungry but you should
probably eat
bye I think
we didn't hit it off Briana Briana we
love you you're so rich she's so rich
who are you
what show are you on I'm hugging
everybody familiar Lily somebody said
what's the difference between the MTV
Movie Awards another award shows and I
said legitimacy I don't know what to say
guys that's all for me today I'm Jamie
Lee I hope you had a good time and
learned a lot you know celebrities
they're just like regular people
but better think about that oh I want
one of those dogs anyways can we get a
shot of the dogs
you